We're asked to evaluate
negative 2 times f of negative 6
plus g of 1.
And they've defined,
at least graphically,
f of x and g of x here below.
So let's see how we
can evaluate this.
Well, to do this, we
first have to figure out
what f of negative 6 is.
So our input into our
function is negative 6.
And we'll assume that's
along the horizontal axis.
So our input is negative 6.
And based on our function
definition, f of negative 6
is 7.
So this thing.
Let me write this down. f
of negative 6 is equal to 7.
And what is g of 1?
Well, once again,
here's our input axis.
And then the function
says that g of 1,
which is right over
there, is negative 5.
g of 1 is equal to negative 5.
So this statement simplifies
to negative 2 times
f of negative 6, which is 7.
So times 7 plus g of
1, which is negative 5.
So plus negative 5, which
simplifies to-- let's see.
Negative 2 times 7 is
negative 14 plus negative 5,
which is negative 19.
And we are done.